[Music]
take a look at this image what might
this be a frightening monster too
friendly bears or something else
entirely for nearly a century 10 ink
blots like these have been used as what
seems like an almost mystical
personality test long kept confidential
for psychologists and their patients the
mysterious images were said to draw out
the workings of a person's mind but what
can inch blocks really tell us and how
does this test work invented in the
early 20th century by Swiss psychiatrist
Hermann Rorschach the Rorschach test is
actually less about the specific things
we see and more about our general
approach to perception as an amateur
artist Hermann was fascinated by how
visual perception of varies from person
to person he carried this interest to
medical school where he learned all our
senses are deeply connected
he studied how our process of perception
doesn't just register sensory inputs but
transforms them and when he started
working at a mental hospital in eastern
Switzerland he began designing a series
of puzzling images to gain new insight
into this enigmatic process using his
inkblot paintings Rorschach began
quizzing hundreds of healthy subjects
and psychiatric patients with the same
question what might this be however it
wasn't what the test subjects saw that
was most important to Rorschach but
rather how they approached the task
which parts of the image did they focus
on or ignore did they see the image
moving did the color on some ink blots
help them give better answers or
distract and overwhelm them he developed
a system to code people's responses
reducing the wide range of
interpretations to a few manageable
numbers now he had empirical measures to
quantify all kinds of test takers the
creative and imaginative the
detail-oriented the big picture
perceivers and flexible participants
able to adapt their approach some people
would get stuck
during the same answer for multiple
blots others gave unusual and delightful
descriptions responses were as varied as
the ink blots which offered different
kinds of perceptual problems some easier
to interpret than others but analyzing
the test takers overall approach yielded
real insights into their psychology and
as Rorschach tested more and more people
patterns began to pile up healthy
subjects with the same personalities
often took remarkably similar approaches
patients suffering from the same mental
illnesses also performed similarly
making the test a reliable diagnostic
tool it could even diagnose some
conditions difficult to pinpoint with
other available methods in 1921
Rorschach published his coding system
alongside the ten blots he felt gave the
most nuanced picture of people's
perceptual approach over the next
several decades the test became wildly
popular in countries around the world by
the 1960s it had been officially
administered millions of times in the US
alone unfortunately less than a year
after publishing the test Hermann
Rorschach had died suddenly without its
inventor to keep it on track the test he
had methodically gathered so much data
to support began to be used in all sorts
of speculative ways researchers gave the
test to Nazi war criminals hoping to
unlock the psychological roots of mass
murder anthropologists showed the images
to remote communities as a sort of
universal personality test employers
made prejudiced hiring decisions based
on reductive decoding charts as the test
left clinics and entered popular culture
its reputation among medical
professionals plummeted and the blots
began to fall out of clinical use today
the test is still controversial and many
people assume it has been disproven but
a massive 2013 review of all the
existing Rorschach research showed that
when administered properly the test
yields valid results which can help
diagnose mental illness or round out a
patient's psychological profile
it's hardly a stand-alone key to the
human mind no test is but it's visual
approach and lack of any single right
answer continue to help psychologists
paint a more nuanced picture of how
people see the world bringing us one
step closer to understanding the
patterns behind our perceptions keep
exploring the inner workings of the mind
with this playlist
[Music]